the drama in Downing Street may be a
hundred miles from Stroud but the noise
is just as loud
trying to make sense of today's
turbulence in Westminster Market seller
Andy he's losing faith
confidence in the current government
really I mean they seem to be going from
one extreme to another
no long-term policies really Saul seems
to be knee-jerk stuff and what we need
is long-term policies that have got
hopefully sort things out
sorting things out is the aim of the
PM's latest move but we couldn't find
many in this marginal seat who think
it'll work the Prime Minister sacked her
Chancellor that's she has she this
afternoon
I I don't know what to make of it it's
ridiculous it was I used to be a member
a member of the Tory party but um I'm
not now but they voted for her they
voted for it the MPS didn't they
shouldn't have had her the sooner they
get rid of her the better I think she's
dealt with a pretty um pretty badly
actually in the last few weeks if you
only when did chicken when how long she
been in two weeks I think I think
they've done too much wrong and it's too
late too bad yeah she started off on air
so yeah and now she's just doing
everything to try and compensate that
but what will happen like
I personally think there should be a
general election
cabinet changes and u-turns to try and
calm the markets are one thing but at
the end of the day the real test May
well come in marginal seats like this
and the question is whether or not the
damage is already done
it's also the case
the global economic
Stroud Bookshop Barbara's digesting the
prime minister's words
well I just think the whole thing's a
shambles and it cannot be good for any
business because we're becoming a
laughing stock she's trashing the
economy I think that this will be lost
unless there's an absolute turnaround
I think this will be lost to labor
presumably
I'm afraid I'm
I just think a period in opposition
might do them good
the PM says she's determined to see it
through the coming days and hours will
reveal whether the damage could be
repaired
demoited Sky News in Stroud